welcome back to Google developers live
here on the chrome channel here for the
final the fifth and final episode of the
Udacity CS 256 office hours the mobile
web development course it's been a blast
for the last five or four times and
limbers our final episode here doesn't
weren't here for the entire flock that's
right I was your trip thank you thank
you for coming back to answer the final
question so I'm here with the Sean
Bennett course architect in the dude
actually Chris Wilson course instructor
and works for Google and myself Peter
lubbers all right so we've got a couple
questions if you have questions if
you're watching live you can still ask
additional questions you can also vote
for questions you do that by going to
developers.google.com/live and then you
find the on-air episode that's airing
right now and then you go to that page
and at the bottom there's a moderator to
ask questions so let's dive right in
with the first question from las vegas
by summer Rae we are we going to cover
the differences between feature
detection versus browser detection using
the user agent and what would be the
best way to accomplish that so who wants
to think that I try to avoid using user
agent if you can right yeah not always
possible but my history and browsers
leads me to believe it's a really bad
thing to linked to specific browsers
just because especially in mobile there
are so many different user agents I mean
there are hundreds if not thousands of
user agents that you can get so strong
strong recommendation use feature
detection moderniser is awesome now
other libraries to you know I just say
go down that path yeah it's way easier
way less painful and they work pretty
well at this point yes yeah well it's
more future proof right if you use
feature detection for those that don't
know what that is is basically checking
and whether the browser supports a
particular feature right and then you
can fall back if it doesn't but if you
use a user agent I mean there's really
no way of telling sometimes user agent
strings are even passed with the wrong I
mean a great example is what the latest
version of ie changed their user agent
did they remove msie I believe in
janja's and just kept Titan right
instead so yeah if you did that then you
wouldn't detect that I 11 and and the
reason for that by the way I'm sure is
yet they had to remove an msie because
so many pages out there that hard coded
in a browser detection string yeah it
said if msie is somewhere in the user
agent then do some porky old thing that
is no longer even remotely appropriate
right or not yeah but there was no other
way for them to get around if those same
pages had used feature detection instead
they wouldn't have this problem right
yeah right yeah it's very hard to do it
right yeah user agent yeah they're just
just incredibly hard day there's a great
a great article about user agent
detection and the history of you is your
agent and I'll try and remember to post
as a response to this that's hilarious
like it in the beginning there was the
user agent and it's it's utterly
hilarious all right yeah I'll try to
remember to post that cool so another
question from summer we are we going to
cover advantages and disadvantages of
using libraries like jQuery Mobile and
other capabilities like canvas whip yo
web sockets so for the latter part some
of those api's didn't make a lot of
sense in the conference app the apps
that we were building you can actually
learn a lot about canvas in CS 255 yeah
it's focused on games but a lot of those
concepts will apply web geo and believe
you yeah we've got a we've got a 3d
graphics course that's taught in WebGL
it actually uses three jas so guys some
of the abstractions a lot of people but
yeah it's if you
want to learn more about that that's
great WebSockets for mobile I mean
that's basically like fine yeah using we
actually discussed it in detail in last
week's episode yeah Chris was on the
beach of course but but as far as i know
a lot of these a lot of those
technologies are supported reasonably
well in various mobile browsers yeah
yeah i think you know canvas WebGL
WebSockets these are really go learn
about how to use those features and
about how to yeah to use them on mobile
mm-hmm but for the first part yea or nay
yeah um no mostly because using
libraries like jQuery Mobile there are
great libraries we really wanted to
teach the fundamentals of how mobile is
different like how what we even mean
when we say develop mobile first and a
lot of those you may not end up looking
at the you know the exact technical
details of the the lessons that we
covered in this later on but you need to
understand why they're there and what
they're doing for you I think that was
what we're really trying to get it
mm-hmm nope perfect alright so next
question from Dakar from bakhoum how do
you think it's possible to build more
web applications with high quality and
awesome design because sometimes it's a
real programming real problem real
problem sorry comparing to native apps
yeah yeah this is one of the biggest
challenges right now is that there are a
lot of things that are not missing
really but maybe a little harder to do
on the mobile web but a lot of that is
because it is this portable platform
that goes across all these different
environments and scenarios and you know
it's relatively easy to write a tool or
support developers who are building
applications that only run on one form
factor of device or to form factors of
device and I think that we're getting
there I think tools have coming in may
yeah distance just in the last year
easily in the last year last six months
see ya at there's some pretty cool stuff
that's happened so I think that we are
definitely getting there I think design
tools in the native at design tools in
the mobile web platform particularly or
kind of an area firm from ya know but i
also think there are some really big
names getting into that space that we're
gonna help ya dramatically the dance
that i've seen out of adobe for example
i was just go to the last year or two
pretty amazing like oh yeah i would have
you know just jumping up and down for
that and a lot of stuff they're doing
they're trying to kind of open source
some of that developer tools to I mean
if you've looked at the brackets editor
for and that's primarily focused on web
development so mobile web development as
well is fantastic so there's a lot of
people working on tooling and I don't
think there's going to be just that one
tool set either I remember even way back
in the day in the late 90s at Microsoft
and we started supporting the web
platform and tools and the interesting
thing was we had multiple different and
wildly different versions of tools like
we had front page it was really more
about like revision control system
almost more than anything you know it
had a WYSIWYG editor that was okay but
certainly not great but they're the
revision control and that the hooking up
to the backend was really powerful and
then we had visual internet i think it
was called which was like the developer
tool and it was you know really helped
you build your javascript but it didn't
know anything about HTML no it didn't
really bring it together anything now
we're starting to see the tools that
bring all of these pieces together yeah
yeah all right so question from pier in
Stockholm any tips for responsive design
media query break point values some
designers argue it's in vain to seek
them but instead to let your specific
layout dictate where they are where they
are Chris you also mentioned let's take
that further yes that's what
yeah break my most good questions should
you use break points oh yeah good I mean
yeah I don't think he's asking whether
you should but like are there specific
values that are going starting points
yes um I I think that holy depends on
the kind of app you're building if
you're building something fairly you
know traditional or typical or some then
there are good you know good ideas to
have but i think the the point that some
designers argue that you know you really
should make these decisions in the
context of whatever you're building is a
really good one nice yeah i think that's
that's absolutely true and you know it's
it's partly your layout and where it
naturally makes sense to start breaking
things it can also be what devices you
think are most appropriate to support
although it was interesting because we
had a talk given by Luke Wroblewski a
couple weeks ago in for our chrome
developer relations team and Luke had
this diagram where he showed like all of
the screen sizes I'm a wide variety of
mobile devices and it was interesting
because you didn't see a lot of
clustering like I would have expected
more clustering around a mobile phone
and size and a tablet size and desktop
is kind of all over the board and there
wasn't as much as you would think there
was so much bleed over between the two
because there are so many devices out
and even he showed the well what if you
just limited to one manufacturer and
shows like Samsung good thing it was
still like there are 20 devices because
they have a huge range and I think
that's the interesting things there are
so many different devices it's harder to
to hook with that and it's really better
to say you know this is well this is
what you're going to get when you run a
device like a mobile phone because this
is how my layout works best on it yeah
and think about how it's going to work
best when you move up to the next device
maybe it just scales up maybe it
then you have room for a little column
next to it and that's really what you
want i'm going to put your toolbar on
the side or things like that so second
part of the question Chris you mentioned
screen proportions 2x 3x how do you use
that I did there is a min and Max device
pixel ratio and a min resolution min max
resolution too I think and as media
query parameters and forget them the
word for that the inputs to tomorrow for
media query rules and I think that you
could just use those to say you know if
you're a minimum device resolution of
this then use this high resolution image
or if you're not the only thing I will
say is make sure to capture both of
those the men and the Mach so that you
don't have a high resolution device
download both images yeah and obviously
always running the profiler and see what
your downloads are go so from Stockholm
we jump to Norway keeping it in
Scandinavia what's the best scenario for
mobile web apps if you want to use
MongoDB no sequel DB not couch TV what
are some good libraries that will take
care of dirty updated missing local
cache hits etc control flow related so
we had an interesting attention about
this one before the show we're looking
through the questions and and this is
this is a tough one and I think Sean you
made a comment that I thought was really
appropriate that you know I think maybe
people are kind of holding their breath
yeah building those libraries partly
because we're waiting for service worker
to come around for those of you don't
know service worker is a way of building
very rich offline abilities by
essentially kind of taking over what the
request system does in the web platform
so when your application says hey I want
this file it doesn't just use this local
cache or hit the network you
own code can figure out what to do
intelligently and that that's one side
of the coin yeah and the other side of
the coin frankly is indexdb I'd love to
say it's deployed on every mobile device
that you might possibly be interested in
sadly it's not yeah the case but it is
getting there but the other thing is you
know doing a local cache database a
locally cached database system is a very
hard problem it really depends on the
scale you're at your exact application I
was telling these guys about when i was
at Microsoft I actually signed up for
the the internal dog food of exchange
very early like in the you know mid 90s
and it took them a long time to get it
perfectly right like to get it to work
super well and offline because it was a
back-end database and a local cache and
you want it to work that way you want to
step onto a plane with no Wi-Fi and have
all of your email there for you in that
scenario but you also want to get you
know delivery of mail instantly ideally
and that was a tough problem and it's
also a different system that you would
want to use for that then you know the
database systems are not
one-size-fits-all and that was kind of
part of the push to use index DB was
giving a low level just the indexed key
storage system and then you can layer on
sequel or whatever variant of query
language you want so the short answer is
I don't think there's a great library
game I don't think there's a just go use
this library and it will all work out I
think in the future you'll probably see
some come up as service worker comes out
and as index DB is deployed everywhere
but it's still going to be a little bit
customized depending on your application
you're gonna have to do some work there
alright so another question I would like
to hear your analysis and comparison of
different html5 to native tools like
PhoneGap ionic titanium and what about
hybrid apps and missing mobile support
on different platforms I guess for
certain features them so any thoughts I
the only one I've used as the phonegap
yeah it's the primary 1i views yeah it's
really easy to use right and it's I
haven't used ionic or titanium I don't
know so I I've looked at them but I
haven't actually built with them so I
guess we can't give you a fair
unfortunately not full because so maybe
look online maybe we can find dig up
some comparisons and I'm sure they will
have their yeah great feature last two
weeks ago we had a similar question and
I looked up and found the comparison of
html5 embeddings on app systems and i
think that there's also the whole second
part of this question which i think is
around what about things that are in the
mobile web platform that are in the
native app platforms right i mean if
there are things there that you
desperately need probably kind of out of
luck unless you can get them added into
the frameworks one of the big challenges
for me has always been the security of
the web platform is a very different
beast than the native platforms and it
probably shouldn't be really because so
many times I you know I have to set up a
new phone because my phone died on me
again yesterday and as I was
reinstalling some of the application
some of the native apps that I used I
realized like you know some of the mask
for really no permissions I think and
you don't really even notice you're like
sure this game needs to read all of my
contacts yeah
well maybe it doesn't actually yeah and
the web by default of course tries to
protect you from all of that and we're
also seeing as chrome is is disabling
the NPAPI plug-in system by default that
we're just starting to do that and this
causes a bunch of scenarios to kind of
come out of the woodwork because a bunch
of people use this for really weird
things with custom plugins I used it for
my web MIDI shim actually okay with that
defendant okay dies if you don't really
but all of those pieces together you
know they kind of help us figure out
what's missing you know platform and I
will say a tremendous number of those
things have gone into the mobile web
platform yeah I mean just looking at the
device access lesson you get a feel for
wow you have access to a lot of neat
stuff yeah that's pretty pretty exciting
and I think that will grow over time
absolutely I mean I mean that will grow
I think we'll see more and more of a
kind of expandable mobile web permission
system at some point you have to be able
to not hit allow every time yeah my
audio recorder web page wants access to
the microphone kind of thing yeah cool
so we have another question from Craig
in Maine maybe something for you Sean
can you talk a little bit about coding
to promote a unit test ability and give
an example of what a unit testable
javascript function would you look like
okay so the the thing you have to do
here is code for testability from the
get-go it is very hard to retrofit
reapplication that in my mind is
probably one of the single that in
performance yeah that was yesterday yeah
it's very well actually three that
performance and offline you kind of have
to keep those in mind security and
security no yeah design for all yes um
you you really have to have to be
thinking about what kind of test you're
going to be writing from the get-go
and design your application to actually
be able to run those tests your code has
to be modular fairly you know small
chunks that you can test unit tests one
at a time you know call one thing mock
it up and see if it works it's really
hard if your app doesn't do that already
to retrofit it it is one of the things
that I've always found in my own code
that that helps to promote good unit
testability is you have to clearly
define exactly what every every function
is going to do yeah because otherwise
like I get in this trap every once in a
while the code that I write with Web
Audio code because it's really easy to
do is you have to be careful about
causing side effects like if you say
well this is supposed to you know set
the frequency of the oscillator but it
doesn't actually also say oh yes and it
starts at playing or some other side
effect you can get in weird situations
when you call something else it doesn't
work but ya didn't have the side of that
right I mean really all of these are all
these concerns are you need to plan your
architecture out ahead of times and
unfortunately well the web makes it very
easy to not do that and kind of you know
play around with things and get
something up and running which is
fantastic yeah but it doesn't often lead
to code that is easily testable or you
know where you have all of this
documented well and you understand from
a broad picture what your architecture
is and what it should be yes yeah i mean
really i think the the short version is
just be intentional mm-hmm when you code
like yeah declare what your intense are
for every function every object whatever
you're doing like this is what this is
supposed to do yeah and it helps other
people tremendously time juice okay yeah
yeah yeah I mean and there are tools you
can use to kind of help with this for
example a.j stock kind of forces you I
mean if you actually J a stock all of
your code and then you know test and
make sure that it does conform to that
your J esta aqui it keeps you thinking
about these things right like what is
passed into here am i testing that
that's what's passed into here what's
returned do I have any side effects good
commenting and good documentation helps
a lot definitely great alright so back
to Oslo how would you wisely split the
native mobile HTML and hybrid parts of
the mobile app cake could you discuss
this linkedin link your Venture heat
article and do you think they would
revert with new tool so I haven't read
this article yet I can probably comment
on a little bit later but the new tools
strikes me as something that there's an
incredible amount of power in for
example the chrome dev tools yeah well
and this article is from about 10 months
ago oh yeah really the you know they're
looking at the tool set as it was a year
of moon right because as they were
developing and a significant
outperformance tooling which has come
just in current like a huge way and that
I'm yes oh yeah so i haven't read the
entire article live you we kind of yeah
that's it i think i read it actually i
remember reading it went ok first came
out and reread it again and i think that
you know it's it i don't expect everyone
to say oh we should totally dumped
native right now today and just do HTML
based development because there are some
some implications there and the toolset
as we've discussed is still kind of in
progress in some places I think it's
come a dramatically long way and I think
it's it's headed in the right direction
certainly
looking at the LinkedIn LinkedIn's
decision a year or more ago to go back
to native after doing after doing web
stuff I don't think they necessarily
made the wrong decision at the time
because they didn't have all that tool
set in front of them I think that some
of the things they say in that article
aren't true anymore because of the dev
tools I think some of them around design
tooling which they only sort of hinted
at those are still probably a kind of
appropriate but I do think they probably
changed your mind about other things but
I will highlight that in the article the
LinkedIn person actually did say you
know we have all of our data in these
object storage systems anyways like all
our data is in JSON so doesn't matter
like we can go recast this and change it
over pretty easily and quickly and you
know you should be doing that yeah you
shouldn't be right on hard coding all of
your data into html5 anyways it should
be a data system that then gets pulled
in yeah and that's I mean if you're
going to be splitting your application
across different technologies that's
even more less crucially important I
mean and as to the first part of his
question how would you split native mo
HTML and hybrid i would say that really
depends on what you're doing too I mean
if you're taking advantage of something
that fundamentally you can't do in in
the mobile web then absolutely go native
yeah I mean right me personally if I can
do it in with web technologies that's
probably the route that I'm going to
choose just because one code base is so
much better to maintain in my eyes than
multiple code bases yes so if I can if I
have that option i'm going to take it
you don't always
no yeah good one yeah and I mean hybrid
is really just a way of getting the
packaging and delivery semantics of
native wall still building in in mobile
yeah yeah the store and is that going to
admin its memory cool all right so our
final question at least for now from the
chair in Stockholm okay it's still
possible so thanks for the awesome
course and the fabulous staff thank you
is there any reason in the flexbox demo
to prefer to section tag over the div
and by the way hope the water was warm
and Hawaii quite 11 / why we live in
nature well thanks appear yeah there was
a good reason for yeah yeah i mean i
don't think this is specific to the
flexbox mo in any way but in general if
you can use a more semantically specific
tag you want to do that but there wasn't
any reason to do that no fluxbox don't
know section ative would work fine
because we didn't have say an article at
a section and all that stuff but one of
the big one of the initial big pushes
with html5 was actually having semantic
content which makes things much easier
to read and parse and figure out that's
really taken what you're doing yeah out
of those tags are now widely used mm-hmm
I think that was one of the earliest
things and now it's basically everywhere
right um yeah semantic markup if you can
do it and if it makes sense yeah all
right well I think that wraps up the
question so we've enjoyed being here for
five weeks in a row hopefully you've had
some help with me with the course I
think we'll probably host another office
hours maybe in March or something in a
month so we can just open that up for
questions ahead of time so stay tuned
for some announcements about when and
how you can ask questions there so all
of these live sessions are also
available in recorded form right after
same URL
that's at developers.google.com / lives
/ chrome and then you can find all the
stuff there we'll also do a blog post
next week on the Udacity website and
kind of recapping the office hours and
making those available so well thanks
Sean yeah thankful to all of you to the
staff in a GD else to do yeah and that's
it for for this time yeah alright see
you soon